chasse à l'homme en allemagne après
l'exécution de france martin schleyer
raymond barre à bonn
il faut que nos gouvernements puissent
renforcer leur action dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme international
valéry giscard d'estaing aux architectes
il faut répondre aux nouvelles
aspirations des français
une avant première antenne 2 l'histoire
du gaullisme et du ps en bande dessinée
mesdames messieurs bonsoir c'était donc
bien cela quelques minutes après que je
vous ai quitté hier de façon un peu
impromptue nous apprenions que hans
martin schleyer était bien mort c'est
son cadavre que les policiers français
allemands devaient découvrir dans une
voiture en stationnement
à mulhouse une audi verte informations
que l'on pressentait dès 6 heures du
soir à suite d'un coup de téléphone
anonyme
ces ravisseurs se sont donc lâchement
venger de l'échec de l'opération
lufthansa et de la mort des trois
cerveau de la bande à baader
l'autopsié du corps de monsieur
meilleures pratiques et il ya quelques
minutes à mulhouse confirmé que le
président du patronat allemand avait
bien été tué d'une balle dans la nuque
alors je vous laisse imaginer un moment
ce qu'a pu être la réaction de
l'allemagne tout entière une allemagne
écoeurait partagé pendant plus d'une
semaine entre l' angoisse et le
soulagement
et puis la peur de nouveaux attentats et
bien cette allemagne l'a traumatisée a
réagi une gigantesque chasse à l'homme a
en effet été déclenché avec ce que cela
suppose comme risque de délation et de
chasse aux sorcières tout coup bonne
philippe gassot
l annonce de la mort d'homme ce martin
flyers toute l'allemagne qui
s'attendaient au pire en espérant
toutefois le miracle a été abasourdi
dans la nuit à l'endroit même de
l'enlèvement
les dizaines de personnes ont apporté
des fleurs et allumer des bougies
le pèlerinage devait se poursuivre
aujourd'hui à 21h30 hier soir les
programmes de radio et de télévision et
est remplacé par les informations
concernant l'événement la mort de
martens lier les visages des terroristes
passer à l'antenne et à 23h le porte
parole du gouvernement annonçait nous ne
leur laisserons pas une minute de répit
les radios passées les voix des
terroristes afin que l'on puisse les
reconnaître éventuellement un dispositif
spécial permet maintenant d'écouter ses
voix au téléphone
l'opération psychologique a commencé
contrôle et remise de tracts
mais ces choix ne sont pas
il y avait des policiers dans toutes les
rues aujourd'hui en allemagne
la photo des terroristes était promise
aux conducteurs pour encore plus de
contrôle
le contrôle ne me gêne pas au contraire
nous vous demandons votre aide
non c'est les voitures haut parleurs il
faut que cesse le terrorisme
il faut nous aider dans tous les
magasins les photos des suspects sont
distribués il faut que tout le monde
soit au courant que tout le monde aide
l'opération psychologique a commencé une
opération de police devraient suivre
dans quelques jours les conclusions
politiques de la série d'événements
dramatiques que vient de vivre
l'allemagne ont été tirées ce matin
devant le bundestag
helmut schmidt devant les députés
allemands a souligné que le succès de
mogadiscio était le résultat d'une
coopération internationale tout à fait
étroite et sans précédent évoquant sur
le fond la question du terrain sur
lequel s'est développé le terrorisme
helmut schmidt et gray le site a compris
que beaucoup de jeunes désapprouve
l'accent exagéré mis par certains sur la
jouissance des biens matériels
il a cependant affirmé qu'une réponse à
la question du sens de l'existence ne
pouvait être trouvée que dans le respect
des valeurs suprêmes de l'état en somme
le chancelier s'est montré prêt à
combattre sans un promu de terrorisme
mais aussi peut-être de mieux tenir
compte du malaise existentiel d'une
jeunesse allemande dont une infime
minorité a pensé que la meilleure
méthode politique était une sorte de
nihilisme
au sommet de son autorité politique
helmut schmidt a vraisemblablement à
l'heure actuelle les moyens de
transformer ses intentions en actes
en face à l'eire john stevenson nommé
new york au fascisme
voilà donc pour l'état d'esprit de nos
voisins d'outre-rhin deuxième contrecoup
de toute cette série de rebondissements
des manifestations dans quelques
capitales européennes des manifestations
d'extrême gauche
ainsi qu'à un ensemble d'attentât sans
aucune victime sur le territoire
français une frontière renforcer
notamment aux endroits généralement peu
fréquentés les riverains n'étaient pas
habitués à ces barrages et à ces
fouilles systématiques de véhicules 200
hommes supplémentaires ont été envoyés
dès les premières heures de la matinée
par le ministre l'intérieur
à toulouse un garage concessionnaire de
marque allemande a été plastiquée ainsi
qu'un autre un peu plus tard et toujours
à toulouse une entreprise de
récupération de vieux papiers a été
incendié elle travaillait avec des
firmes d'allemand
en début de soirée ces attentats ont été
revendiqués au nom de groupes autonomes
en liaison avec la mort d'andreas baader
en italie une dizaine de villes ont été
le théâtre d'attentats notamment venise
bologne gêne et rome d'où nous viennent
ces images enfin dernière conséquence il
y aura bien une grève mondial des
pilotes de ligne du 25 octobre 12h au 27
octobre 12h gmt c'est à dire 13 heures
en france le syndicat français des
pilotes de ligne y suivra le mot d'ordre
de grève
voilà c'est dans ce climat très
particulier que raymond barre est arrivé
à l'heure du déjeuner à bonn pour une
visite officielle s'achèvera demain
tout d'abord bien sûr il ya eu les
félicitations de raymond barre pour
l'heureuse issue de la sphère du brain
détourné et puis le remerciement
d'helmut schmidt pour la coopération de
la police française dans la sphère
schleyer cela dit au centre des
entretiens il ya surtout la politique
économique et la politique militaire en
venant à bonn raymond barre veut
rassurer helmut schmidt et être rassurés
par lui en effet dès leurs premiers
entretiens cet après midi le premier
ministre français a pu être rassuré sur
la réalité de la relance économique
allemande et sur l'harmonisation des
politiques économiques des deux pays
cette harmonisation devrait permettre de
lutter d'une façon plus efficace contre
le chômage
à cet égard le premier ministre français
aura demain des entretiens avec les
ministres allemands de l'économie et les
finances
deuxième volet la politique militaire
l'allemagne qui se souvient avec émotion
de la sphère des missiles plutôt veut
être rassurée par la france sur
l'attitude française vis-à-vis de l'otan
sur la place qu'occupe la rfa dans la
défense française et enfin le changer 10
me demandera certainement plus de
précisions concernant les propositions
françaises en vue d'un désarmement
mondial et puis encore un détournement
dans l'actualité sans commune mesure
avec celui la lufthansa
un avion de ligne américain à 737 lui
aussi se diriger vers quand tu as it is
le pirate de l'air qui a fait débarquer
les femmes et les enfants
il réclame la libération d'un prisonnier
à atlanta en géorgie et une somme de 3
millions d'heures dans l'actualité
française d'abord une série de mesures
pour favoriser la mobilité des jeunes et
des familles on cite toujours l'exemple
américain
les habitants ils sont prêts à changer
de lieu de résidence pour trouver du
travail
la phénomène beaucoup plus difficile à
faire accepter en france il passe il oui
c'est plus difficile effectivement en
france d'inciter les gens à aller vers
les emplois lorsque les emplois ne
viennent pas alors aujourd'hui on a pris
on à préciser certaines de ces mesures
qui ont pour but d'inciter les
travailleurs aller chercher ces emplois
première question qui est concerné bien
ce sont tous les gens qui ont été
licenciés pour des causes économiques
ce sont également les jeunes à la
recherche d'un premier emploi se sont
également tous les travailleurs d'une
entreprise se décentralise par exemple
qui quittent la région parisienne pour
aller en province
deuxième question temps peut-on avoir
droit à ces aides les galas le critère
qui a été retenu est de 20 km
c'est-à-dire que lorsque l'on quitte son
domicile que l'on fait 20 km pour aller
où plus d'un évidemment plus faim à
partir de 20 km pour les chercher un
nouvel emploi eh bien on a le droit à
certaines de ces aides doivent donc la
mobilité de l'emploi n'est pas forcément
de la longue distance mais elle est au
niveau de la région et du département
alors je vais donner si vous le voulez
bien deux exemples de ces aides d'abord
les primes que l'on peut toucher mais
vous pour un travailleur par exemple
licencié pour cause économique city est
célibataire il va toucher 5000 froid
pour faire c'est un patineur 20 km à
partir de 3 ans franc de trois enfants
vous pouvez toucher 12530 à noter qu'un
jeune travailleur à la recherche d'un
premier emploi
s'il fait huit au moins 30 km oui aussi
par étrangers ce qui est plus gênant ce
qui fait plus jeunes bien s'il part
l'étranger pour aller travailler dans la
filiale d'une entreprise française et
bien il a lui aussi une prime de 5000
faut enfin précisé de mesures pour le
logement là pour le logement si vous
êtes propriétaire de votre appartement
de votre pavillon que vous allez
chercher un nouvel emploi que vous avez
donc besoin d'une nouvelle maison d'une
nouvelle maison
le passé deux choses si vous êtes
propriétaire et que vous voulez le
vendre pour acheter une nouvelle maison
pendant deux ans on va vous prêter de
l'argent en attendant que vous vendiez
votre ancienne maison afin de pour en
acheter une nouvelle deuxième la loi
2006 voulaient la loue et alors c'est là
c'est la deuxième formule même si vous
avez eu des prêts publics et en principe
lorsque les prêts publics vous devez
absolument occuper cette maison est bien
deuxième formule vous pouvez continuer à
garder votre ancienne maison en la
louant un autrement une nouvelle alors
il faut dire que toutes les précisions
sont fourni par l' agence nationale pour
l'emploi
valéry giscard d'estaing veut promouvoir
une architecture la française voilà ce
qu'il a dit il ya une heure à peine
devant un parterre d'architectes réunis
à paris au palais de l'unesco
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
mais la mort que les constructions
publiques ne seront plus réservées à des
petits groupes d'architectes ensuite que
ces constructions là seront désormais
différente variés on ne retrouvera plus
l'éternel se s standard
et puis enfin les particuliers pourront
à tout moment demander conseils
gratuitement dans chaque département sur
la qualité de
architecture qu'ils envisagent et valéry
giscard d'estaing en annonçant ces
mesures investi les architectes d'une
nouvelle mission
je crois qu'on peut dire que la rapidité
du développement économique et le
bouleversement des structures humaines
et sociales ont fait oublier la mesure
l'équilibré l'harmonie nécessaire aux
hommes pour vivre mieux
on n'a pas pris suffisamment en compte
les fonctions sociales de la ville on
risque d'engendrer l'insécurité le
déracinement puis la solitude les
contraintes techniques économiques
financières réglementaires et
administratives ont pris hélas je pense
qu'en dix ans et là sous le dernier avec
moi
le pas sur les besoins sociaux et
culturels
on dirait presque que la construction
après être arrivé trop tard a dû arriver
trop vite la nouvelle attente des
français
les nouvelles données de l'urbanisme
d'aujourd'hui sont pour les architectes
une nouvelle sauce car ce n'est pas en
confiant l'aménagement de la cité aux
seuls spécialistes du trafic aux seuls
ingénieurs ou seul sociologue que l'on
créera des villes animées et chaleureuse
une ville est un enchevêtrement
extraordinaire de fonctions multiples et
la synthèse ne peut pas ignorer la
dimension de l'art et de la culture
c'est pourquoi le rôle des architectes
est maintenant de définir l'art urbain
de la fin de ce siècle la ville
d'aujourd'hui la ville de demain ne peut
pas se faire sans vous en élargissant le
champ de votre mission en prenant les
dispositions nécessaires
l'état est résolu à favoriser en france
une vaste demande d' architecture il
s'agit à la fois d'assurer le meilleur
emploi des architectes
il s'agit aussi de recréer une nouvelle
architecture française digne de notre
pays faut dire que les français dans
leur ensemble et l'architecte eux mêmes
ne sont pas très satisfait des
réalisations des constructions ces
dernières années et le constat qu'en
dresse j'en fais yeux et finalement à
s'épaissir non autour et au grand
ensemble oui à la maison individuelle
selon un sondage récent huit français
sur dix ne veulent pas d'immeubles de
plus de trois étages pourtant que ce
soit 1 ampère ou ici à bordeaux on est
loin du compte
la dernière invention des technocrates
c'est la tour sur dalle qui comme aux
olympiades à paris créer une ville dans
la ville
j'ai le sentiment d'être
un peu en claustrophobie ins la dalle
c'est rien c'est du béton
quand on est enfermé en est fort on est
qu'au niveau de la rue donc on a pas de
communication avec la rue bien qu'on ait
pour certains bâtiments les nuisances de
la rue la défense cent quinze mille
personnes en 1981 une mégapole
ingouvernable et un million cinq cent
mille mètres carrés de bureaux au lieu
du million initial car elle depuis des
années a été la dérogation pour
retrouver cet habitat à l'échelle
humaine souhaitée par le président de la
république il faut d'abord changer
l'état d'esprit de l'administration les
comités de défense
en lorraine comme ailleurs ne veulent
plus voir le coeur de leur ville
saccagée par les bétonneurs comme la
place stanislas
défiguré par une tour de 50 mètres et
tour de la ville ont d'ailleurs coûté
son siège à l'ancien maire monsieur main
respect du site
la mairie de l'étang la ville en at elle
bénéficié mais il n'ya que dix
inspecteurs des sites pour toute la
france les collectivités nationales
aussi sont responsables d implantation
très belle construction que cet hôpital
à poissy mais en pleine campagne avec un
bus toutes les demi heures
que dire de ce plan neige qui pourra
tirer l'or blanc a planté les cubes de
béton à haute montagne
l'argent c'est là où le terrain n'est
pas cher que ceux construits chaque
année 50 mille maisons de ces nouveaux
villages qui constituent le quart des
maisons individuelles
deux français sur trois veulent une
maison individuelle pourquoi la maison
individuelle parce que
chez moi j'ai du terrain autour de moi
ces différentes de la vie en appartement
vous avez vécu en appartement un
appartement pendant quatre ans alors le
plus gros inconvénient milan contre l
agression de transport pour les
personnes qui travaillent à pas c'est le
cas de mon mari
disons que ça lui ça me ferait 3 et à
les transporter
copies de copies les villages des
promoteurs ne brille pas pour leur
originalité
les élus de la nation n'encourage pas
davantage la création
témoin cette annexe du sénat à paris
valéry giscard d'estaing souhaite
encourager l'innovation
un exemple savez le voir cette maison
écologique présenté lors du dernier
salon les décorateurs aux médiocres au
niveau de l'architecturé française il ya
peut-être une explication 70% de ce qui
se construit se fait sans architecte
la nouvelle loi prévoit leur
intervention a eu d'éduquer les français
une tâche immense
un retard de 30 ans à combler
et voyez-vous ce qui est curieux c'est
que certains architectes français qui ne
pouvait pas suffisamment s'exprimer à
travers le plan d'ensemble d'une ville
en france est décidé à s'attaquer à un
morceau de choix la reconstruction de
beyrouth
il faut dire que là-bas tout ou presque
est à faire un an après la fin
officielle de la guerre civile a rien
n'a encore été entrepris mais les plans
et la maquette de la nouvelle ville sont
déjà tracées
dans beyrouth encore en ruines le
bulldozer reste le roi
malgré la paix syrienne qui règne au
liban depuis un an une timide
reconstruction vient seulement de
commencer dans le centre commercial au
paradis de la spéculation immobilière
personne n'a confiance dans l'avenir les
pays du pétrole comme l'arabie séoudite
qui a promis 100 millions de dollars
n'ont toujours pas débloqué les crises
dans une mairie de fortune un nouveau
beyrouth
et pourtant dès les plans ont été conçus
par une poignée d'architectes français
de l'atelier parisien d'urbanisme et
approuvé par la municipalité de beyrouth
l'idée maîtresse est l idée de base
d'ouvrir cette ville vers la mer de
relever ici nous avons entre les
religions deux hôtels et la région du
point une partie qui est verte qui va
liaison des maisons des hôtels au port
et dans notre côté vous allez avoir une
liaison de ce port là vers le centre
ville le centre de gym traditionnelle
là vous avez les anciens sont des
légumes aux aviez les use avait toujours
les grandes mosquées ligue en église
dont il servit cette région qui servira
du sol de centre culturel et que tu elle
aussi est un centre civilisation tout
cet ensemble des zones et par des hommes
vers des zones piétonnières ce qui
pourra assurer d'abord une ouverture
vers la mer et en même temps une
certaine liaison calomnieuse mais en
attendant les crédits beyrouth reste
défiguré avec ses 6000 magasins détruits
et ses 28 appartements bombardé saccagé
et pillé les petits marchands qui
faisait le charme du centre ville ont
repris le travail dans un centre
commercial sans eau et sans électricité
ne savent même pas s'ils devront plier
bagage pour laisser la place à de
nouveaux boulevards ou à des espaces
verts et si leur magasin sera rasé ou
reconstruits on n'a pas le droit de le
réparer afin que
nous avons des choses le permis de la
reconstruction exemple poursuit de
nouveau et aménager de nouveaux magasins
mais en principe on vous a dit que vous
pourriez rester ici dans le sens reims
nos s'ils veulent faire du jardin et
bien beaucoup d endroits web de la ville
de beyrouth robillard hall du centre
commercial qu'on peut faire les jardins
aller 5 1 km après beyrouth tous les
montagnes et des vallées sont 202 points
pour le pouvoir c'est à dire sentir
l'air pur le nouveau beyrouth qui sera
terminée dans dix ans si la confiance et
les capitaux reviennent aurait pu briser
le ghetto se sont formés à travers
l'histoire mouvementée du liban mais les
chrétiens ne veulent pas que l'on
déplace les églises les musulmans
refusent que l'on touche aux mosquées le
beirut de demain ne sera pas encore un
modèle de réconciliation
la politique française avec d'abord
cette déclaration de georges marchais
sur notre antenne il y à peu près une
demi heure le parti socialiste a été
sensible aux pressions de la droite
cela explique tout ces reculs a dit
leader communiste dans l'émission la
parole est aux partis politiques autre
initiative du pc pour la première fois
les journalistes pourront assister le 10
novembre prochain à la réunion du d'un
comité central élargi du parti
communiste les communistes qui enfin ont
présenté leurs candidats pour les
prochaines élections
à noter à un grand rajeunissement et une
féminisation poussé deux fois plus de
femmes qu'il ya cinq ans 160 titulaire
ou suppléante
en tout les gaullistes aussi de leur
côté ont publié une première liste de
225 candidats titulaires
il y en aura une autre enfin les
giscardiens donneront demain une liste
de 110 candidats sur les 250 à 300 qu'il
compte présenter
et puis toujours dans cette optique
d'initiative nous sommes en mesure
antenne 2 vous présenter en avant
première ce qui sera à je crois qu'être
le petit événement politico littéraire
l'histoire du ps et celle du rpr en
bande dessinée georges des loups oui je
pense d'ailleurs que les hommes
politiques seront nombreux à se rendre à
l'espace cardin samedi et dimanche
prochain pour la convention de la bande
dessinée ils pourront y rencontrer 2 140
dessinateurs de toutes tendances
pourront faire leur choix et voir
notamment quelques-unes des planches qui
constitueront l'histoire du parti
socialiste et puis l'album sur charles
de gaulle les français et le gaullisme
alors je vous en ai apporté quelques
dessins quelques dessins originaux
alors pour l'histoire les prévenus du ps
françois mitterrand a rédigé la préface
et c'est daniel meier qui supervise les
textes et le scénario les dessins sont
de paul gillon et puis cela commence
alors je pense que maintenant on va
peut-être voir les images au congrès de
nantes le 17 juin dernier un jeune
couple tout h et il se voit d'ailleurs à
leurs vêtements à leur attitude décide
de se comporter en journaliste
en historien et ce jeune couple va re
découvrir les origines du parti
socialiste ils vont remonter le temps
vous avez vu les barricades la sphère
dreyfus et puis je reste bien sûr mais
ils sont passés entre temps par la
bibliothèque pour les chercher encore
d'autres documents du côté des
gaullistes ce sont michel debré et
lucien neuwirth qui se sont transformés
en goscinny si vous voulez et qui en
établit les textes c'est le dessinateur
chilien victor de la fuente qui a
réalisé lui la mise en scène il s'agit
là aussi d'un jeune couple mais là c'est
un couple avec enfant résolument moderne
et on le voit à leur tee shirts qui
l'université américaine avec les grands
eu les numéros derrière et ce couple se
rend avec ses enfants
colombey-les-deux-églises c'est le père
là qui entreprend de raconter à ses fils
l'histoire du gaullisme et on voit que
l'on prend entre 15 13 15 ans alors vous
voyez
évidemment les images de guerre et puis
on écoute aussi on voit les arrestation
par la gestapo
ici on écoute londres enfin les poupées
du gaullisme pendant la guerre et il y a
une chose quand même qu'il faut noter
c'est que d'un côté les gaullistes et
les ps se sont adressés au même éditeur
pour publier à 500000 exemplaires à
partir du 15 novembre
tenez vous bien ce c2 alors la faim que
nous et qu ministres une série
d'informations brésil via un coup d'état
sans violence en thaïlande
un an après leur prise du pouvoir les
militaires renforcent leur emprise sur
le pays
tentative d'assassinât contre le nouveau
président norgay minutes qui lui a pris
le pouvoir il ya à peine une semaine
après l'atterrissage un premier
décollage d'essai pour concorde à new
york toujours pas de manifestations anti
concorde et puis un nouvel exploit des
plongeurs de l'opération janus 4
deux d'entre eux ont séjourné pendant 20
minutes à 501 m de profondeur c'est un
record mondial
enfin le congrès de criminologie de nice
au programme de cette première journée
la délinquance écologique un domaine du
droit qui fourmille de réglementations
diverses mais dans lequel il reste
beaucoup à faire
ces vagues cette baie de nice où le
soleil concrétise parfaitement
l'objectif du 17e congrès de
criminologie de questions comment
définir la délinquance écologique
quelle formule juridique trouvée pour
limiter ces délinquants ce philosophe et
juriste ne cachent pas leur embarras
en effet le dommage écologique n'est pas
toujours facile à constater et à
délimiter
il peut être il est souvent d'ailleurs
invisible difficile à localiser et
surtout s'étendre sur le futur de telle
sorte qu'on ne peut estimer exactement
le dommage
au moment où l'on juge son auteur
d'autant que le pouvoir administratif ne
laisse pas forcément aux citoyens le
droit de s'informer en outre la
délinquance écologique on peut l'appeler
la pollution sur toutes ses formes
s'abrite souvent derrière des règles
économiques de rendement et de
production qui sont imposés entre
guillemets aux pollueurs par les besoins
de confort de notre société
enfin troisième notions générales
troisième casse-tête en matière
d'écologie les conséquences de l'acte en
sont finalement plus importantes que
l'acte lui-même
alors comment mesurer la réparation
comment par exemple obliger le pétrolier
à nettoyer complètement la mère le roi
dagobert dont on sait qu'il est mais
l'ordre obligé le pollueur d'une
fontaine à la nettoyer et à payer six
soldats mende aujourd'hui on peut se
demander si cette notion de réparation
et bien réalisme premièrement la
réparation est un droit ceci dit elle me
paraît nécessaire car s'il y a les
pollutions accidentelles
il ya des pollutions dues à la
négligence qui sont absolument
inadmissibles et même criminels celle au
cyanure par exemple
devrait être très sérieusement
sanctionnés en somme vous êtes partisan
d'une répression très dures et sévères
en matière de l'élégance écologique
ça n'est pas par le plaisir d'être au
répressif je dis simplement qu'il s'agit
de savoir si un polder qui n'a pas
l'esprit civique peut faire le calcul
suivant qu'est-ce qui me coûtera le
moins cher de nommer qui paie pour ne
plus polluer ou de me laisser condamnés
à des amendes qui me font faire des
économies c'est tout le problème
donc il faut que ce soit dissuasif un
choix politique c'est un choix politique
car c'est une folie les résultats du
kart et enghien le 12 le 11 8 et le sexe
les rapports vous les découvrez sur cet
écran pour 5 francs plus de 12 millions
de centimes dans l'ordre un petit
million dans un ordre différent à 23h31
très précises
dix minutes avant le journal hervé
claude la rédaction vous offre 10
minutes deux buts non-stop
les buts de la coupe d'europe de
football hier mais d'ores et déjà pour
vous mettre en appétit les bus des
rencontres qui a intéressé les clubs
français nantes mise à part puisque vous
avez pu suivre le match hier soir en
direct sur internet
les autres rencontres donc sur la
pelouse du stade de furiani bastia en
bleu accueillait newcastle dernier du
championnat d'angleterre de première
division
mais un club anglais dernier de son
championnat est toujours difficile à
manille et cc anglais que l'on
n'attendait pas si brillant qui ouvrait
la marque dès la 8e minute par k-now
les corses allait accuser le coup mais
en coupe d'europe qu'ils ont des
ressources et en deuxième mi temps sur
deux accélérations de leur capitaine
claude papi il allait marquer de but de
but qui leur permettait d'obtenir une
victoire peut être un peu tiré par les
cheveux mais qui leur permettra d'aller
à newcastle dans quinze jours avec un
but d'avant sur la pelouse du stade
olympique de rome
lens a bien tenu le coup sauf pendant
100 secondes et pendant ses cent
secondes entre la 30e et 31e minute les
lensois ont concédé 2 après ils se sont
bien repris et un bon racing de lens sur
sa pelouse à bollaert dans quinze jours
peut remonter ses deux buts concédés aux
robes donc rendez vous pour cette
tranche de football à 11h30 la météo de
demain bien le temps sera encore chaud
pour la saison mais souvent nuageux avec
quelques pluies éparses sur les massifs
montagneux et peut-être un peu sur le
sud et l'est
il fera beau en bretagne et partout
ailleurs dernière des éditions du
journal je vous le disais 23h41 donc et
avec l'aude avec des images très
spectaculaire d'un incendie à cologne
qui a peut-être un rapport avec
l'assassinât le monsieur schleyer faute
à tous une très très bonne soirée à
l'ecoute de la nouvelle émission de
pierre bellemare à demain bonsoir